if government
naturally wants to buy stuff it can't
afford
what's the best form of government
anarchism
libertarianism so not even go there's
not even armies there's no
borders that's anarchism the least
the smallest possible
the smallest possible
the best government would be the least
and the debate will be over
that when you think about the stuff
do you think about okay government is
the way it is i
as a person that can generate great
ideas how do i operate in this world or
do you also think about the big picture
if we start a new
civilization somewhere on mars
do you think about what what's the
ultimate form of government
what's uh at least a promising thing to
try
you know um
i have laser eyes on my profile on
twitter
what does that mean and the significance
of laser eyes is to focus on the thing
that can make a difference yes and
if i look at the civilization
i would say
half the problems in the civilization
are due to the fact that our
understanding of economics and money is
defective
half
50
i don't know it's worth 500 trillion
dollars worth of problems like
money uh
money represents all the
economic energy and the civilization and
it kind of equates to all the products
all the services and all the assets that
we have and we're gonna have so that's
half
the other half of the problems in the
civilization are medical
and
and military and political
and philosophical
and you know
and uh natural
and i think that there are a lot of
different solutions to all those
problems and they're all
they are all uh
honorable professions and
and they all merit a lifetime of
consideration for the specialist in all
those areas
i i think that
what i could offer it's constructive is
inflation is completely misunderstood
it's a much bigger problem than we
understand it to be
we need to introduce engineering and
science techniques into economics if we
want to further the human condition
all government policy is inflationary
you know and another pernicious myth is
uh inflation is always
and everywhere a monetary phenomena so
you know a famous quote by milton
friedman i believe it's like it's a
monetary phenomena that is inflation
comes from expanding the currency supply
it's a nice phrase
and it's oftentimes quoted by people
that are anti-inflation
but again it just signifies a lack of
appreciation of what the issue is
inflation is
if i if i had a currency which was
completely
non-inflationary if if i never printed
another dollar
and if i eliminated fractional reserve
banking from the face of the earth
we'd still have inflation
and we'd have inflation as long as we
have government that that is capable of
pursuing
any kind of policies
that aren't
in themselves inflationary and generally
they all are so in general
inflationary is the big
characteristic of human nature that
governments collection of groups that
have power over others and allocate
other people's resources
will
try to
intentionally or not hide the costs of
those
allocations like in some tricky ways
whatever the options ever available
you know hiding the cost is like is like
the the tertiary thing like
the the primary goal is the government
will attempt to do good
right and and that's the fundament
that's the primary problem they will
attempt to do good and they will and
they will do it and they will do good
imperfectly and they will create
oftentimes uh as much damage
more damage than the good they do most
government policy will be iatrogenic it
will it will create more harm than good
in the pursuit of it but
it is what it is the secondary
the secondary
issue is they will unintentionally pay
for it by expanding the currency supply
without realizing
that
they're
they're actually paying for it in
in a sub-optimal fashion they'll
collapse their own currencies while they
attempt to do good the the tertiary
issue is they will mismeasure
how badly they're collapsing the
currency
so for example if you go to the bureau
of labor statistics you know and look at
the numbers printed by the fed they'll
say oh it looks like the dollar has lost
95 of its purchasing power over 100
years
okay they sort of fess up there's a
problem but they make it 95 loss over
100 years what they don't do is
realize it's a 99.7 loss over 80 years
so they will mismeasure just the
horrific extent of
the monetary policy in pursuit of
the foreign policy and the domestic
policy which they
they overestimate
their budget and their means to
accomplish their ends and they
underestimate the cost
and and they're oblivious to the
horrific
damage that they do to the civilization
because the mental models that they use
that are conventionally taught
are wrong right the mental model that
like it's okay we can print all this
money because the velocity of the money
is low
right because money velocity is a scalar
and inflation is the scalar and we don't
see two percent inflation yet and the
money velocity is low and so it's okay
if we print
trillions of dollars well
the money velocity was immediate
right the velocity of money through the
crypto economy
is 10 000 times faster
than the velocity of money through the
consumer economy
right it's i think nick pointed out when
you spoke to him he said it takes two
months for a credit card transaction to
settle
right so you want to spend a million
dollars in the consumer economy you can
move it six times a year
you you put a million dollars into gold
gold will sit in a vault for a decade
okay so the velocity of money through
gold is point one
you put the money in the stock market
and you can trade it once a week the
settlement is t plus two maybe you get
to two to one leverage you might get to
a money velocity of 100 a year
in the stock market
you put your money into the crypto
economy and these people are settling
every four hours
and and you know if you're offshore
they're trading with 20x leverage so if
you if you settle every day
and you trade the 20x leverage you just
went to 7 000.
yeah so
the the velocity of the money varies i
think the politicians they they don't
really understand inflation and they
don't understand economics but but you
can't blame them
because the economists don't understand
economics because the because if they
did
they would be creating
multivariate computer simulations where
they actually put in
the price of every piece of housing in
every city in the world the full array
of foods and the full array of products
and the full array of assets
and then
on a monthly basis they would publish
all those results and where and that's a
high bandwidth
requirement
and i i think that people don't really
want to embrace it and and also there's
the most pernicious thing
like there's that phrase
you know you you can't
tell people what to think but you can
tell them what to think about the most
pernicious thing is
is i get you to misunderstand
the phenomena
so that even when it's happening to you
you don't appreciate that it's a bad
thing and you think it's a good thing
so if housing prices are going up 20
percent year over year and i say this is
great for the american public because
most most of them are homeowners
then i've i've misrepresented a
phenomena inflation is 20 percent
not 7 percent and then i've
misrepresented it as being a positive
rather than a negative
and people will stare at it and you
could even show them
their house on fire and they would
perceive it as being great because it's
warming them up and they're going to
save on their heat costs it does seem
that the cruder the model whether it's
economics whether it's psychology
the easier it is to weave whatever the
heck narrative you want
and not in a malicious way but just like
it's it's some some kind of like uh
emergent phenomena this narrative thing
that we tell ourselves so you can tell
any kind of story about inflation
inflation is good inflation is bad like
the cruder the model easier just to tell
a narrative about it and that's what the
so like if you take an engineering
approach
it's i feel like it becomes more and
more difficult
to run away from sort of a true deep
understanding
of the dynamics of the system
i mean honestly if you went to 100
people on the street you asked them to
define inflation how many would how many
would say
it's a vector tracking the change in
price
of every product service asset in the
world over time
no not me now
if you if you went to them and you said
you know do you think two percent
inflation a year is good or bad
the majority would probably say well
here it's good you know the majority of
economists would say
two percent inflation a year is good
and of course there's
look at the ship next to us what if i
told you
that
the ship leaked
two percent right
of its volume every something right the
ship is rotting two percent a year that
means the useful life of the ship is 50
years now ironically that's true like a
wooden ship had a 50
year to 100 year life 100 be long 50
years not unlikely so when we built
ships out of wood
they had a useful life of about 50 years
and then they sunk
they rotted there's nothing good about
it right you build a ship out of steel
you know and it's zero as opposed to two
percent degradation
and how much better is zero percent
versus two percent
well
two percent means you have a useful life
of
you know
it's half-life of 35 years
2 2 is a half-life of 35 years that's
basically the half-life of money and
gold
if i store your life force in gold
under perfect circumstances you have a
useful life at 35 years
zero percent is a useful life of forever
so zero percent is immortal
two percent is 35 years average life
expectancy
so that the idea that you would think
the life expectancy of the currency in
the civilization should be 35 years
instead of forever is is kind of a silly
notion but the tragic notion is
it was it was you know
seven into seventy or ten years
it's been the money has had a half-life
of ten years except for the fact that
in weak societies and in
argentina or the like the half-life of
the money is
three to four years in venezuela one
year
so
the united states dollar
and the united states economic system
was the most successful economic system
in the last hundred years in the world
we won every war we were the world
superpower our currency lost 99.7
percent of its value and that means
horrifically every other currency
lost everything right in essence the the
other ones were 99.9 except for most
that were 100 because they all
completely failed
and uh
you know you've got a you've got a
mainstream economic community you know
that thinks that
inflation is a number and two percent is
desirable
it's it's it's kind of like
you know remember george washington you
know how he died no
well-meaning physicians bled him to
death
okay the last thing in the world you
would want to do to a sick person is
bleed them right in the modern world i
think we understand that that oxygen is
carried by the blood cells and
and you know
and
if uh
you know there's that phrase right uh a
triage phrase what's the first thing you
do in an injury
stop the bleeding single first thing
right you show up after any action i
look at you stop the bleeding because
you're going to be dead in a matter of
minutes if you bleed out
so
it strikes me as being ironic that
orthodox conventional wisdom was bleed
the patient to death and this was the
most important patient
in the country
maybe in the history of the country
and it's and we bled him to death trying
to help him so when you're actually
inflating the money supply at seven
percent but you're calling it two
percent because you want to help the
economy
you're literally bleeding
the the free market to death
but the sad fact is george washington
went along with it
because he thought that they were going
to do him good
and
the majority of of uh the society most
companies
most most conventional thinkers
you know
the working class they go along with
this because they think that someone has
their best interest in mind and the
people that are bleeding them to death
believe
they they believe that prescription
because their mental models are just so
defective and their understanding of
energy
and engineering and
and uh and the economics that are at
play
is uh is crippled by these mental models
but that's both the bug and the feature
of human civilization that ideas take
hold they unite us we believe in them
uh
and we make a lot of cool stuff happen
by
as an average sort of just the fact of
the matter
a lot of people believe the same thing
they get together and they get some [ __ ]
done because they believe that thing and
then some ideas can be really bad and
really destructive but on average the
ideas seem to be progressing
in in the direction of good
you